[Music]
Hello,
I'm
going to start my presentation on the topic of printing receipts with React.
These days, I'm interested in the Rust language with this cute mascot, so I
'm trying to handle it well. I'm
currently
working as a front-end developer at Toast Place. You
may be unfamiliar with Toast Place, but Toast Place is
now offline payment  It's a
company that makes a service for the bosses to make sure that the
market is like this. What I want to talk about today is about
receipts.
How
did I do it?
Like the code on the right, I wrote a receipt output code using React like this.
Today, I
would like to share my experience with you about what problems there were and how I came to write this code using React.
I came to make a course one day Does
anyone know what POS is?
Maybe if you have experience working at a store, such as a convenience store or restaurant, you've probably
used it at least once.
A boss is a device that looks like this.  It's a
system that handles management tasks, and
hardware and software are collectively
referred to as POS.
Now, for example, we go
to a restaurant,
order food,
enjoy the food, and pay when we leave.
If you do, we will give you a card, and
there is a device that looks a bit big, and
after you make a payment, you
click on it, and the payment is completed, and a
receipt is printed out, so
you take it off the video and get the receipt.
Now it's a boss
machine, but as you can see, the POS machine has
a lot of complicated UI on the display that can be touched like this. The
POS machine manages a lot of things such as ordering and payment, so there are a lot of
things to print.
I'm a consumer, so I
only knew about receipts.
There was also an
order form, and the receipts we learn or the bills that customers leave for the table were also printed.  By
the way, it is
made of special paper.
Stores usually use a printer called a summer printer in
English, a thermal printer. A
thermal
printer is a
method of printing by applying heat to paper.
I know this was very unusual. This
thermal transfer printer is characterized by
using special paper, so the maintenance cost is
a little high, but it prints very quickly and
does not require ink,
so it is
used as the preferred printer in stores. In
future announcements, the word printer  There will
come out a lot, but if you
think of a printer here, you can think of this thermal printer. If you
look at the back of the thermal printer, it
usually consists of this as shown in the picture above.
Well,
printers that are slightly more expensive also support Bluetooth and the like.
Here, the store says that they connect to the boss machine mainly through a
serial port.
What is a serial port? It was the first word I ever heard in my life.  It
means serial port, but serial communication
is now one of the physical interfaces.
Serial communication literally
refers to a method of
serial communication.  But now the
name has the meaning of serial.
Serial port generally refers to hardware that
conforms to the standard of rs23.
Usually, what the speed is now, for
example, now the most used
speed is 115,200 bps, but now
bps means 1  It's the number of bits sent per second.
So 115,200
bps would
be 11.52 kilobytes per second.
USB 2.0 can theoretically transfer about 60mb per second.
So,
serial ports are still widely used in industrial settings. The
physical interface standard that looks like this
is RS or higher, but if you
look at old computers, you will see these standards now and then.  I
used it to connect the same peripheral devices.
Now I'll tell you how to control the serial port with JavaScript.
There is a way to use it as a node. There is a
node serial port live, so
this is a third-party library.  It is
provided as an api, and there
is a method that can be used even on the web. There is a web
serial api provided experimentally.
And each is now
provided as a streams api. Let's take a
look at the web serial api.  You
can open the port using this, but
now you have to enter the value for the baud rate. To
put it simply, you can think of this baud rate as the
number of bits transmitted
once per
modulation.  By transmission, so you
can just think of the baud rate as having the same meaning as bps.
So, the number of bits sent per second
is 9600.
I need it. I
'll explain why. For
example, let's talk about
when data is transmitted like this from the transmitter to the receiver.
Here, the transmitter is
tx and the receiver is rx.
For example, there is a
positive voltage and a negative voltage, and
now, in the case of the December port, it is
recognized as 1 of the positive voltage. In
this way, the signal can move.  I
can,
but is this correct?
Actually, unfortunately, I
can't say it's perfectly right.
For example, I can read it like this. In other words, you need the wire speed to
read the data correctly.  You have to
come back and
open it using the bud rate,
and you
can read and write data from the open port with a read or write interface. Now,
when you write data, something
comes out.  If not, it might be a bit unfamiliar, but
now JavaScript
provides an array of types that can handle binary data.
One of these
types is uint8, and I'll explain a little bit about un.  You
can think of it as an array that contains the
text ad. For example, if I take charge of the text ad in ASCII encoding, the
first column will contain public interest 60 days public interest
62 in this way.
A1 will contain two spaces like this, and the
other two spaces will now pull the same ab.
Similarly, if you
encode once with utf8, you
can see that you pull 5 spaces in this way.  I'll
probably actually
write a code for the printer. I'll bring a writable interface to the port here,
encode the value Hello world into ASCII, and
try portaying it.
Then,
surprisingly, there is no response.
Is the printer broken?  Until you enter the output command, it
continues to accumulate in the buffer. So, you have to
enter the printer output command so that the
printer realizes that it has to print for the first time and prints it.
Then what the hell is the
output command? There is an output command called ESC force.
However,
escp
is one of the languages ​​for printer control called Abson Standard Code 4 Inters.
Usually, now this EST postpy
command is
used like an industry standard, and
ESC force is now a type of escpa, which is a
printer command command system made by Abson,
and now in POS  It is a command language
compatible with most used thermal printers. If you
look at an example of a command, for example, the
line feed ASCII code Now, the one
corresponding to lf executes the insemi gang.  As
you can see, I think the first letter was named esc
because esc is mainly used as a prefix.  I
will insert a command that prints and print it. There is a
hello world, and
after line feed, if you
insert a command to initialize the printer and print it out,
you can see that hello world is printed in this way.
For example, I will try to print Hangul once,
but unfortunately summer
printers do
not support utf8.  There
is a command.
By using this, you can specify a character set for the code page.
So, if you
enter 13 for n, it will be encoded as baby food kr. If you
put the command corresponding to esdr in the data and
encode the hello with euckr, then
output it
like this  You can check that it is output like this.
In addition, there are various commands. Well, you
can cut the printed paper, or you can change the
font size, or something
bold, or something, change it to alignment,
change the size, print a barcode,
or print a QR code.
By using these various commands, you can now enclose a printout that is close to the receipt you received at the store,
but the part that creates the output data earlier is
very dirty.  I
thought of doing it. The
printer object internally
holds the data for the command command, so it
does a new line.  If you use Yin-tae and
objects,
printer
output becomes easy. If you
create a printer object and
specify a character set, or
change the text size,
change it online, print the text, and
get data, printer
data is
easily created like this.
This is enough for usability.  This
looks good, but
in fact, most of the rivals that I have found to
support the esg post commands
have been implemented with this interface. But I
thought there was a little more improvement.
For example, if you
think of it as a ui that is output to a printer rather than a domino of a browser, now the
existing printer is making code close to the left.
Directly creating dom elements,
setting properties, and such cumbersome
procedure-oriented language, procedural
code comes out,
whereas on the right  The code
shows at a glance what the ui wants to express.
So, if I also think receipts are a
kind of UI expressed by printer output, I
thought it would be better to express the data to be printed in a declarative syntax.
Even the
code is a bit short,
so the project is now
using React, so I have
jss  I thought it was
easy to write receipt data declaratively using
syntax. How can I use React? For example, let's
say you have a
receipt that looks like this.  If you
think about it and
divide it into compartments, for example, the entire
receipt can now be captured as a printer component, and the
left alignment test
can be divided into text components centered text like this.  If
you express it,
I think you can express it like this.
Then, it
goes all the way to creating this jsx code. How can I change this now?
Now, the cool thing about React is that you
just declare how to draw the ui, and the
renderer puts the right data at the right time and
puts the right data in the environment
Render it in the right form. For example, in the
case of React DOM, it is now
rendered as a DOM in a browser environment,
or in the case of React Native, it is
rendered in a native UI.
In the environment, you
will be able to render in a form that supports the ESC force command.
In other words, I think you
can think of a render that receives an email react element and converts it into a sentient 8 array. If you
use this render function, the
receipt code you just created  By changing it in this
way, you
can print it from the light of the port. In
this way, I will now print out a complex receipt.
And looking at the code on the right, I thought it was a good thing that it
could be easily predicted to be output slightly to the left.
Now, how can I implement a random function?
No, so I
thought I could just create an output command to output from each node while looping through the React child nodes.
So, for
each component, I
declare a function called print that now generates an output command.
When you receive an element, you just
have to run this print function while traversing each child node.
Then, after
traversing, the data will have accumulated on the printer, so if you
do that, the
receipt output data in the form we want
will be returned.
Actual implementation is a bit more complex  If you
explain it conceptually, you can see it like this.
Now, if I write my receipt
like this in React syntax, there is another good thing. That is, it is
possible to render in an environment with a
DOM.  You
can draw it like this using a renderer,
or
now you need a printer output. Then, if you render it as per the printer output, you
can output a receipt in this way.  You
can easily make a preview of how to output. Yes, I
did a fun job by customizing the render of React in this way, but
there were actually a number of packages made by customizing the renderer.  In the
case of rendering using Act Component,
there was a library called Ink, and now it is said to produce pdf.  I
think it was a very touching experience that fits Ennea very well.
This is what I wanted to share.